desde este martes la bandera finlandesa
ondeará en la sede de la otan la
organización celebrará la integración
más rápida en la historia moderna de la
alianza un proceso que acaba con siete
décadas de neutralidad militar en
helsinki creo que nos dará seguridad es
algo que hemos esperado mucho tiempo
tengo sentimientos encontrados no soy el
mayor fan de la otan pero todavía menos
de Rusia
la ofensiva rusa defendida por Vladimir
Putin como una respuesta al acercamiento
de occidente hacia las fronteras rusas
refuerza la otan y la lleva más cerca de
Moscú Finlandia y Rusia comparten 1.300
kilómetros de frontera desde el Báltico
hasta el Ártico donde el kremlin ya ha
anunciado que va a reforzar su presencia
militar
no tenemos disputas territoriales con
Finlandia y Suecia como tenemos con
Ucrania no nos preocupa si se convierten
en miembros de la otan Ahora si la otan
despliega tropas en sus territorios
estamos obligados a responder con las
mismas amenazas que enfrentamos Suecia y
Finlandia presentaron sus candidaturas
de adhesión a la otan conjuntamente el
año pasado Sin embargo la aspiración
sueca continúa bloqueada por Hungría y
Turquía ankara pida estocolmo la
extradición de militantes kurdos a los
que acusa de terrorismo
que Finlandia sea miembro de pleno
derecho va a reforzar la seguridad y la
integración de Suecia en la otan lo digo
porque no debemos dar la impresión de
que Suecia se queda sola el Beto Turco a
Suecia puede levantarse en función del
resultado en los comicios de mayo en que
se decidirá el futuro político del
presidente erdogan donde el ejecutivo ya
está de salida es en Finlandia este
domingo lo socialdemócratas de saramarin
perdieron los comicios ante el partido
conservador y la ultraderecha sin
embargo antes del cambio de gobierno el
actual ministro de exteriores verá como
la bandera finlandesa se iza en Bruselas